Well, now for the answer--the issue with html input of course,
is that it contains confidential information.
We really don't want the entire world to know who we are
and which websites we visit.
So, we have seen that there is indeed confidential information in here.
If we center out this data in order to reproduce the bug,
this means that the sensitive data may be out of control.
This means that developers may get access to it
with plenty of possible issues that follow.
There are multiple solutions to that.
First to keep the data secret, for instance you could sign
a nondisclosure agreement with your customer
before you ever get access to such data.
The second option is simply to anonymize the data.
That is, you produce a version of the data
with the sensitive information removed.
You can also use a technique like Delta Debugging
to simply file the input automatically
and to keep only those characters that are actually required to reproduce the failure.